>> Tucker: GOVERNMENT WORKERS
AND STUDENTS AND ABOUT A TOTAL
OF 10 PRIVATE SECTOR EMPLOYEES
ENJOYED THE DAY OFF FOR CLBLDZ.
-- COLUMBUS DAY.
SOME WANT IT CALLED INDIGENOUS
PEOPLE DAY.
COLUMBUS, OHIO, IS DITCHING
COLUMBUS DAY AND CELEBRATING
VETERANS DAY IN INSTEAD.
THE AUTHOR OF "ERASING AMERICA"
JOINS US TONIGHT.
THIS IS PART OF A LARGER TREND
YOU WRITE ABOUT IN YOUR BOOK
WHICH I HOPE OUR VIEWERS READ.
TELL US WHAT THAT TREND IS.
>> WELL, THE TREND IS TO MAKE US
ALL FEEL ASHAMED TO BE AMERICANS
AND LOOK AT EVERY ASPECT OF THE
AMERICAN STORY AND SAY THE
FOUNDERS WAS BAD AND THE
CONSTITUTION IS RACIST.
WHAT BETTER PLACE TO START THAN
WITH CHRISTOPHER COLUMBUS?
HE WAS PATIENT ZERO OF THE
EUROPEAN INVASION OF AMERICA.
>> Tucker: I COULD NOT AGREE
WITH YOU MORE.
WHAT IS THE POINT OF THAT?
WHY WOULD THEY WANT TO DO THAT?
>> WELL, THE POINT IS IF WE FEEL
BAD ABOUT OUR COUNTRY AND ABOUT
THE PAST, THEY CAN REWRITE ANY
FUTURE THEY WANT.
PROGRESSIVES WANT TO TURN THE
UNITED STATES INTO A SOCIALIST
COUNTRY.
IF YOU SAY EVERYTHING IN THE
PAST IS BAD, THEY CAN COME UP
WITH A FUTURE THAT FITS WHATEVER
THEY WANT TO MAKE IT.
>> Tucker: THEY ARE TELLING THE
REST OF US YOU DON'T HAVE THE
RIGHT TO DEFEND YOURSELF AGAINST
OUR ASSAULTS?
>> OH, DEFINITELY.
IT'S ABOUT SHAME AND BLAME.
THE ASSAULT ON COLUMBUS.
AS A BUCKEYE I AM SAID ABOUT
COLUMBUS, OHIO, DITCHING THE
HOLIDAY.
I THINK THEY SHOULD CHANGE THE
NAME OF THE CITY.
>> Tucker: I AGREE TO INDIGENOUS
CITIES.
>> [LAUGHING].
OR VIRTUE-VILLE.
>> Tucker: [LAUGHING].
OBVIOUSLY THIS HAS BEEN GOING ON
IN ACADEMIA FOR SOMETIME.
IT SEEMS TO HAVE SPREAD TO
COLUMBUS, OHIO, WHICH IS A GREAT
TOWN FILLED WITH NORMAL PEOPLE.
>> WELL, I THINK IT'S BEEN
INSINUATED INTO THE AMERICAN
EDUCATION SYSTEM FOR DECADES.
STARTING IN THE 1970s, WE HAD
REVISIONISM IN AMERICAN HISTORY
BOOKS.
WITH COLUMBUS, HE STARTS CHAPTER
1 IN THE REVISIONIST HISTORY OF
AMERICA.
PEOPLE SAY COLUMBUS IS A BAD
GUY.
>> Tucker: UNBELIEVABLE.